this is sort of a big progressive media
story that happened during our vacation
so I want to spend a little time talking
about it the the young turks founder and
host jancuga
resigned from justice democrats over
some i guess the best way to
characterize the miss sexist blogs that
he wrote years ago that resurfaced and i
have some thoughts about this but first
i should kind of just lay out for you
the basic facts and the moving parts of
this so first and foremost the young
turks it's a progressive independent
media network that started just as one
show started by Genki auger years ago
it's grown dramatically a few years ago
they did a three to four million dollar
fundraising round more recently they did
a twenty million dollar subsequent
fundraising round this is a relatively
large non huge media company i guess we
would say for independent media or at
least what started as independent media
they are very very big that's the young
turks justice democrats is a political
organization that supports sort of more
to the left progressives in elections
and this includes the primary of
Democratic incumbents that they find to
be moderate to conservative not to the
left enough okay jenk was involved in
founding justice Democrats now it to be
a hundred percent clear with you last
time I saw and spoke to jenk was in
October I've not spoken to him about
this I've not spoken to anyone at the
Young Turks about this and everything
I'm going to tell you is my opinion and
and the facts are all things I've
gleaned from what's publicly available
these blog posts written by jank
surfaced from the early 2000s on the rap
calm the rap com-pub lished them and
gent wrote things including that the
genetics of women are flawed because
they don't want to have sex as often as
needed for the human race to get along
peaceably that's one thing gent wrote in
these uncertain fost blog posts Jenk
wrote in another one that physical
intimacy with women should progress in a
particular way on date three four five
between a man and a woman he wrote about
kissing twenty three women and touching
quote countless breasts in New Orleans
during one Mardi Gras and there were a
few other blog posts that were
similar similar statements in the
blogpost what did Jenks say about this
he said a few things okay number one
Genk wrote that when he wrote these
things he was still a conservative and
that he doesn't stand by them anymore
that he stands by any conservative
politics from his past
jenk also said that the blog posts were
exaggerated and that they were written
deliberately in a satirical way and
number three Jenks said that these posts
and the the statements in the posts have
actually absolutely no connection to his
views on these issues today okay how
much of this resonates with me and how
much of it doesn't well number one jenk
was a conservative growing up but my
understanding was that he was a
conservative when he was much younger so
like in 2002 that's fifteen years ago I
think he's about 47 now he would've been
32 I thought that his conservatism was
more when he was like in college but
maybe I could be wrong about that I
voted for Al Gore in 2000 voted for Al
Gore in 2000 conservative at that time
maybe middle-of-the-road
I don't know but so that that
explanation to me is not the strongest
one right I'm not really sure about that
as far as this is like any other view
that I used to have that I no longer
stand by that actually does make sense
to me okay because he were talking here
about things he thought at the time but
no one has ever accused jenk of actually
having done anything wrong when it comes
to his interactions with women working
at the Young Turks for more than ten
twelve I don't even know how many years
at this time we're talking about views
he held that he and many others now
disagree with so he eventually resigned
from justice Democrats over this should
he have resigned from justice Democrats
well it became a major distraction so in
that sense it probably was hurting the
organization that Genk was still
involved but again the difference
between Jenk and many of the other
incidents that we've heard of in media
over the last year or two is that Jenk
is not accused of having done anything
he had unsavory opinions 20 years ago
opinions he has changed his mind about
I've said before Pat and I think you've
heard me say this when I was in high
school I didn't really think
transgenderism was legitimate right I
thought gay lesbian bisexual totally get
it exists across hundreds or even
thousands of species
not something that people choose etc in
my mind when I was in high school and
even maybe early in college I questioned
the legitimacy of transgenderism I've
since learned more about it and changed
my mind now I never blogged about it but
had I written a blog about my views on
transgenderism at age 18 and decided to
make them satirical in nature or sort of
written in a way to create more of a
reaction it probably would be pretty
cringe-worthy to read that hypothetical
blog right now now I never wrote the
blog and more importantly I never acted
on it right I never discriminated or
insulted anyone based on their
transgender status whatever if a blog
had been written by me when I was 20 and
it was surfaced now should that impact
me today I don't think so it's just it's
a view that I changed my mind about and
I also got the sense that he was being
glib about it that he didn't actually
feel this way maybe he was just like a
sexually frustrated young man at the
time and he was trying to blame the
opposite gender rather than looking
inward I guess maybe so yeah and and
this is not a defense of what he said I
think I don't know of any people on the
Left who were defending the content of
what Jenks said in fact I think it's
mostly people on the right that are
defending the content of what Genk said
the group just as Democrats though has
now severed ties with Genk they also
severed ties with Dave Koehler who's a
co-founder of The Young Turks I've known
Dave Koehler for a long time he was the
treasurer of the Justice Democrats and
he also used degrading language in a
blog post 14 years ago about some woman
that he and or generally women that he
and Jenk met on a road trip I don't have
anything else to say about Dave Koehler
and then lastly Kyle kolinsky who's a
friend of our show and host of secular
talk who I guess was an advisor or a
board member or a co-founder I'm not
exactly sure what his role was at
justice Democrats he also resigned I
have no thoughts about that he can do
whatever he feels is best for him period
I know people were emailing and saying
David will you comment on Kyle Cole in
Skees resignation I don't really know
what his role or degree of involvement
was with justice Democrats and he
clearly did whatever he thought was best
at the time he was in a very tough
position did what was best for him yeah
of what I couldn't possibly comment on
that so bottom line
these are fringe
worthy blogposts there are no victims
there are no accusers of Genk at the
young turks which again has been around
for 12 years or even longer i don't know
how long
allegations of wrongdoing or one thing
but people having previously held
unsavory opinions especially when
they're very upfront that these are
pinions they now find a plural and no
longer hold to say that that's a
disqualifier for progressive involvement
their credentials it is problematic to
me and there are people who are saying
this is an example of the left not
supporting free speech justice democrats
severing ties with Genk the right and
left both have a history of supporting
the speech that they like and not speech
that they dislike and now this movement
for absolutist absolutism when it comes
to free speech has sort of taken hold in
some places on the internet you can find
examples of both the left and right
becoming authoritarian on the issue of
free speech in different instances this
for me is not a story about the left and
intolerance of different ideas if
anything it's more a story about how all
of these stories have become blended
everything from actual accusations of
wrongdoing sexual assault or harassment
of women and merely sort of immature and
retrograde and unsavory ideas that
someone expressed at a certain point
those are just not the same things Pat
and I think that's the main point for me
yeah I mean ever since the Harvey
Weinstein things started people have
been trying to rank you know what's
worse what what Bill Cosby did yes is
you know maybe Mark Halperin right and
where it all plays in sure this is this
totally separate category because he
didn't act on any of this stuff comments
if someone comes forward and says Genk
did act on this that changes the story
but as of now that has not happened and
no one is even talking about that as a
possibility there's just zero behind
that those are my thoughts if I'm off
base here if I'm blinded or biased by
the fact that I've known genk since 2008
which is not that much later than when
some of these blog posts were written
and there was nothing in 2008 that
indicated that he even remotely held
these opinions send me an email and say
David you were blinded by knowing Genk
here is why you
should be more critical of what it is
that he wrote and what happened here
send me your thoughts we'll take a break
and be back after this